[Musique]
il était une fois un village du sud
touraine de 340 âme aux confins de la
brenne et du poitou le petit précis ni
le savoureux un nom idéal pour
accueillir depuis les années 60 une
famille de cuisiniers
c'est d'abord lucienne la mère qui a
tenu la promenade le bar restaurant du
village avant de laisser ses fourneaux à
son fils jacky un amour de la cuisine
qu'il a su transmettre à son fils
fabrice revenu au pays pour prendre la
suite
[Musique]
quand j'étais tout petit je faisais des
cakes je faisais des barbre est vraiment
laid mais bien sauf que quand je faisais
la vaisselle jusqu'à sait beaucoup de
choses donc fallu que j'arrête
j'ai fait d'abord la cuisine et après
j'ai fait la pâtisserie mais j'ai
toujours aimé la pâtisserie ça c'est un
vieux dessert donc j'avais fait ça pour
championnat de france des desserts en ya
20 ans mais pas du tout comme ça et une
évolution évidemment et j'avais fait
donc c'est un genre de tiramisu
revisitée avec une mousse fromage blanc
avec un croustillant parmesan et à
biscuits imbibés au café et une plaque
de chocolat ça fait un tiramisu revisité
mais complètement
améliorez quoi ça va de saint jacques
ont suivi une cote de cochon c'est en
1999 à la naissance de son fils que
fabrice a quitté paris pour revenir au
petit précis ni un parcours débuté en
touraine ou lycées mallié chez charles
barrier alain couturier des étoiles les
tourangeaux avant les grandes maisons de
guy savoy et pierre gagnaire mois manon
bédard éric cheverou peur de cape town
hôtel de sévery et vous monsieur queue
de cochon et périls des glaces et de
tomates en dés reach ou accompagner tous
les une tête en éther méthyl 16 ans
pierre gagnaire c'est un peu une cuisine
intuitive ou hop il ya quelque chose qui
arrive on réagit et guy savoy c'est
plutôt dans le produit comme on fait
voilà quelque chose de classique et le
produit est maintenant je m'en rends
compte que par rapport à ça ils m'ont
aidé les deux différemment quand on
arrive de grandes maisons c'est vrai
qu'on dit ah bah on friday de deux et
trois étoiles c'est facile mais quand on
arrive chez nous on a l'impression
d'être chez nous qu'on fait pareil et
c'est pas ça pas facile au début de
travailler avec son père surtout quand
il a un caractère bien trempé une
gouaille une bonne humeur qui anime
toujours la cuisine
même à la retraite jacky reste
consultant au restaurant 5 heures par
semaine en toute décontraction faut bien
occuper
tu as vu le temps qui fait pour faire du
jardin alors et puis je suis pas très
jardinier mais dans l'ombre aux bouquets
près j'ai beaucoup moins vite qu'avant
prend du temps pour lire le journal
occupe une épaule
et ils robinet qui fuit
donc tout ça c'est la cuisine sympa
c'est à quelques kilomètres du
restaurant h au musée que jacky retrouve
sa mère lucienne car la cuisine chez les
dalles et c'est une histoire de famille
mitonné à la géline de touraine ou
légumes du jardin et à l'amour filial
jeunes ont été arrêtés entre 160 il y
avait il y avait le bar et petit à petit
beau match de suite vise à faire un
petit peu de cuisine familiale que
j'avais l'air présentant les ouvriers
roma est arrivé comme ça
après on a fait quelques transformations
et puis voilà
il voit là la suite la suite qui va doit
s'arrêter là mais est ce que ça vous
fait plaisir de voir que votre fils
votre petit-fils peut-être votre arrière
petite fille nue et oui c'est plus grand
plaisir qui seul qui puisse me farah
oui enfin jacques il a beaucoup avec sa
femme dany a beaucoup travaillé pour
tous à nous quand on a commencé on a
commencé à continuer ce qu'il faisait
quand même c'est à dire bistrot menu du
jour où on vendait du gaz
ça commençait un petit peu 80 85 86 ans
a eu les ouïes millau fait que ça qui va
un peu lancé on avait des nappes en
papier quand même les nappes vichy les
bed apprend papier on est 14 15 go avec
ça quand même
démarrant dont il a eu sa première
étoile semble alors c'était la folie
parce que vous auriez imaginé ça vous
non nous non plus 15 16 puis 17
gault et millau une étoile au guide
michelin en 1989 pour cet ancien de chez
robuchon le resto familial devient
gastronomique avec une nouvelle
clientèle
mais pas de quoi tourner la tête de
jacky toujours gourmand des farces de sa
mère ma mère quand elle faisait des
crêpes que c'était la chandeleur fait
des crêpes pour le pour les clients du
jour alors mettez de la ficelle de
l'angoissé alors évidemment à plier la
grippe et quand tu manges et ben
[Musique]
mercredi 16h30
après les deux jours de fermeture
hebdomadaire fabrice part à la recherche
des meilleurs produits légumes volailles
il est au plus près de chez lui comme
son père avant lui prend son lait à la
laiterie de verneuil 200 litres par
semaine
pour moi c'est important mais il préfère
me déplacer parce que on voit le produit
on rencontre les personnes mais surtout
à la cie des gens qui faisaient moins
moins bon pour moi j'irais pas même si
sa côte est il faut quand même toujours
avoir la qualité mais comment la la
qualité à côté de chez nous alors on y
va les chercher
depuis un an et demi fabrice a choisi de
diversifier son activité en fabricant
des crèmes dessert avec le lait de la
coopérative un partenariat gagnant
gagnant
la laiterie distribuer ces crèmes sur la
france avec une vente directe à verneuil
250 pau par semaine
un début prometteur donc ça fait treize
mille par an
donc avec ça on dit bon on peut voir un
peu plus loin et tous les gens qui
viennent en famille le week-end de paris
quand il ya des vacances viennent
chercher les crèmes 1 c'est quand on
vient à paris c'est quand donc ça m'a
mis le pied à l'étrier tout ça tu vois
depuis un entretien à ouest ya bien eu
raison de venir faire le test chez nous
d'un côté pour lui c'est intéressant
d'avoir des fournisseurs qui sont
proches
il connaît la presse et la provenance du
lait il connaît beaucoup de nos de nos
éleveurs donc c'est important pour lui
en termes de sécurité
il connaît la qualité de
l'approvisionnement et d'un autre côté
nous notre lait est transformé dans un
trou dans un produit noble par un grand
chef donc c'est tout à fait c'est aussi
pour fabrice dalé qui a beaucoup d'amis
agriculteurs sa façon de les soutenir en
valorisant leur les essais dans son tout
nouveau laboratoire qui fabrique ces
crèmes
sans colorant ni additifs question de
qualité là je prépare la crème pralinée
pourquoi c'est lui je sais pas des fois
le problème c'est que on a un métier de
fou like ou cuisinier dans un restaurant
qui fonctionne très bien mais la vie on
sait pas ce qui a pu être fait donc du
jour au lendemain peut-être que ça
marchera moins bien à peut-être que
alors voilà j'ai une route comme on dit
j'ai une roue de secours
on sait jamais mais ça reste toujours
les coups
le restaurant dont cinq ans à loïc et
puis mon associé et qui vont travailler
ici c'est le début d'une nouvelle
aventure pour fabrice qui vise
aujourd'hui une clientèle locale et
parisienne avec 800 poli vrai chaque
semaine à rungis une diversification à
taille humaine
[Musique]
retour à la promenade où l'on retrouve
isabelle la femme de fabrice et dany
celle de jacky d épouse discrète qui ont
toujours épaulé leur chef de marie une
atmosphère familiale qui se ressent
jusque dans les repas pris en équipe
avant le coup de feu
c'est mieux que de perdre les patrons
d'un côté le monde on travaille tous
dans le même bateau
on n'est pas toujours d'accord à thann
après voilà c'est sa politique
[Rires]
j'ai connu fabrice il était encore à
l'école
ok c'est ce qu'a encore gamin et puis on
s'entend bien on s'est toujours bien
entendu on appuie à peu près les mêmes
idées un petit peu pour tous donc ça
s'est fait naturellement
et voici constance 15 ans jean constance
la fille de fabrice aimerait devenir ce
molière
j'adore quoi bon comment s'est passée ta
journée à la rochelle abolissez alors on
va là péter ciconstances souhaite
rejoindre le lycée hôtelier de la
rochelle c'est au cfa de tours que nous
retrouvons son frère clément d'aller 19
ans déjà un cap2 pâtisserie en poche il
prépare celui de cuisinier
oui aux délices part de la recette
l'occasion de partager son histoire
familiale son expérience mais aussi ses
doutes avec ses camarades
j'ai pas le même la même expérience que
mon père mon grand père c'est quelque
chose que oui je m'étais mis la pression
tout seul en me disant ils ont plus
d'expérience mais c'est normal ils ont
eu un passé ils ont travaillé sur des
grandes maisons moi je suis encore
apprenti
parce que tu comprends quand même
l'impression qu'il peut avoir justement
je pense pas que je pourrai l'assumé
parce que moi je pense que je vais être
le premier déjà et j'ai du mal avec la
fumée et j'ai du mal mais oui sachant
qu'il ya déjà du monde qui est passé
avant et caen sont sûrement fait de
grandes choses avant lui il obligé passe
au dessus parce qu'il a eu le temps
d'apprendre de voir les erreurs prendre
ce qui est bon ce qui est mauvais et la
croissance provient du combattant obligé
d'exceller donc déjà tu que tu veux
faire quoi de ces tu traînes quoi je me
dis à tes gars ont un projet pour
commencer à pcc de ce serait de faire
les saisons pour voir autre chose
voyager découvrir d'autres produits
parce que si je reste ici je vais pas
forcément faire de nom parce que sinon
ça va être trop facile je vais je rester
dans le cocon familial on va dire mais
c'est parce que parce que j'ai envie
pendant
auger respirer un autre air que quelques
petits précise jacky et fabrice régale
aujourd'hui les gourmet qui s'aventurent
jusqu'au petit précis ni un
bouche-à-oreilles élogieux et une
cuisine créative de saison fait avec
passion nourrissent la fidélité des
clients depuis 34 ans conseille de faire
notre travail le mieux possible puis
c'est tout on est con on n'est que des
cuisiniers des passeurs de plats et
essayer de faire plaisir aux gens le
maximum mais c'est ça faire plaisir le
principal je crois que c'est d'être le
préféré je pense qu'on fait partie des
préférés des clients
la famille d'aller c'est aussi une
histoire d'attachement d'amitié ce soir
là des amis vie en cuisiniers et trente
ans de maison contre la vieille le
sommelier des pics ans j'ai vu toutes
les générations nous début je faisais
laquelle avec le grand père bon
malheureusement jeu
gérard est décédé et puis je travaillais
enfin moi le chef quand je dis chef
c'est le vieux mais bon fabrice et mon
patron c'est moi le mais c'est le chat
fille sage active
jacky c'est mon c'est un gamin il a un
mois de moins que moi donc je sais pas
on a des relations qui ce qui dure
depuis déjà un certain temps
quelquefois faut le supporter un petit
peu mais mais en général ça se passe
assez bien plus tôt même très bien ça
vous fait plaisir justement de voir que
c'est fabrice maintenant raja qui
reprend ça fait plaisir à tout le monde
ça fait plaisir je pense à son père
aussi de devoir qu'à maison continue
dans le avec un style qui évolue mais
dans le dans la même lignée évidemment
que c'est important qu'on se sera le
petit fils on sera un petit peu plus
vieux on commence à en verser un petit
peu de vin mais on sera toujours là
c'est sûr perdu cela fait 30 ans qu'une
étoile brille sur la maison d'aller au
petit pressing c'est désormais la
quatrième génération de cuisiniers qui
se prépare à écrire une nouvelle page de
l'histoire familiale
[Musique]